When your app gets great new information your user may love
How he can share this information without interrupting it
I'm Joanna Smith, and I'm here to tell you
How a snackbar can change your life forever
Or at least the life of your application.
One of the most important points in communicating information in your app
Related to the notifications on the screen
But when that information is vital
Or require the user to make a decision, you often have to use an "alert"
Historically, you have two options here.
First, a dialogue should clarify that new information to users
So that they can act accordingly
But the dialogues are very intrusive
And force users to stop what they do to deal with your dialogue.
I mean, do you enjoy being interrupted?
Do you like to confirm that you really wanted to do something that you were already doing?
Do you like urgent dialogues?
I mean, that's pretty annoying, is not it?
Therefore, the use of dialogues should be minimized,
Which brings us to the second choice .. Toast
Which you can use to confirm that what the user has done,
Has already occurred.
But what if the act is destructive such as "cancel"?
Your user may not have done that
Now he is horrified to look for retreat
He wonders why he was not sure twice before canceling
That's the perfect picture
My God!
Are you trying to spoil my life?
Here comes the role of Snackbar.
"Snack bar" is similar to "toast" but more versatile
Because it is more interactive, such as displaying the Undo option
Which your users are still searching for.
"Snack bar" moves up from the bottom of the screen
You can also wipe it away with your finger, or not.
If you do nothing with him, his time will end and he will disappear on his own
The Snack Bar contains a short message
And can display one action as "undo".
So now you have three components that will help you better boycott your users
Use the dialog when the user response is central to the performance of your app
Because you need to be a breaker at those moments
But, use "Toast" to give your user little information that will not change anything.
And for everything between them, "Snackbar" is your new favorite friend
And so, a wonderful principle for another physical design came back to life in your application.
So check the design library
To get all the support you need to use Snack Bar in your application
Enjoy a world of non-interrupt alerts
But what is more important is to continue to build better applications.